well what a night joining us now is the
chairman of the conservative party
oliver dad and very good morning hello
good morning dad and let's start by
talking about last night if we may um an
absolute dropping wasn't it what went
wrong
well voters in north shropshire were fed
up and they gave us a kicking
and i think they wanted to send us a
message and i want to say as chairman of
the conservative party we've heard that
loud and clear
we need to get on with delivering the
job and that's precisely what we're
doing for example with the booster
programme to deal with its omicron
variant we've administered over 700 000
vaccines just yesterday i would though
say that these are quite unique
circumstances
and in a by-election like this you would
expect the opposition party of the
labour party to be surging they were
strong second and in fact they're
sinking but it wasn't normal by election
dynamics was it and you talk about
special circumstances but really um
you've gifted this to the lib dems and
you say that they sent you a message the
voters there what is the message that
you're receiving and is it an
endorsement do you think of your leader
well voters are clearly fed up and they
want us to get on with the job and focus
on the job and our job as a government
particularly at a time of crisis like
this is to make sure we're focused on
the core priorities number one is to get
on with delivering the booster program
that's the way we stay open and we
maintain normal life during this very
difficult period the prime minister's
put turbo boosters under that and we've
had over 700 000
boosters administered the prime minister
on the economy we've we've got some of
the lowest unemployment since before the
crisis that's where our focus isn't
about the booster jab is it this is a
referendum on the prime minister
effectively is he still an electoral
asset for the conservatives yes i think
the prime minister is an electoral asset
for the conservative party and i'll tell
you why just take the three really big
calls we've faced get brexit done he's
delivered on it we've delivered the
fastest people would say they're not
scientists we've delivered the fastest
booster program
in the world twice over and we've seen
the economy through this terrible period
with unemployment lower than when we
entered so i think actually on the big
calls the prime minister has the vision
and the direction to get us through this
difficult period a lot of the red wall
tories there were going to be worried
aren't they and any tory indeed with a
slim majority they're going to be
worried about their seats you've got a
problem well
we see results like this
mid-term it's it's the case it happens
time time again you know between 1989
and 2014 we didn't win a single
by-election in government we lost brexit
to the liberal democrats before the 2019
election we won it back if the liberal
democrats did as well in by-elections uh
in general elections they don't buy
elections they've been in power for the
past 50 years it is the case that people
have sent us a message we've heard that
message but i wouldn't extrapolate too
much through to the general so
mumbling's about no confidence in the
prime minister are conversations being
had behind closed doors and letters
being written
i have no idea where the letters are are
being written but i have every
confidence the prime minister has the
leadership to see us through this period
and i think
he he has shown whether it's in relation
to getting brexit down or this latest
record-beating booster campaign that
he's got that drive and determination
again we'll come on to the booster
campaign i know you're clearly very keen
to talk about it more stories though
today uh in the day's papers uh your
leader himself the prime minister is
accused of attending a party at number
10 during the first lockdown your
comments on that please well i
understand that this was a meeting that
took place in the garden
actually it was the case at the time if
you're going to have a meeting you're
better off having it outside because of
the the fresh air and and ventilation so
will questions be asked will there be an
investigation into that well i've seen
the the account given by by downing
street that this there was a meeting
that took place and it took place
outside i think that was a perfectly
appropriate and reasonable
there had been a press conference
previously
and it was perfectly reasonable to have
the meeting afterwards outside so will
simon case be looking into the details
of that one as well i don't think
there's a need for the cabinet secretary
to look into this one because the the
circumstance appeared to be pretty clear
um cchq we understand again from the
papers that police are quizzing two
people um about that party that took
place there with sean bailey is it right
that police are quizzing two people that
were there at cchq and they're not
looking into what happened at the
various parties that are being alleged
at number 10.
well you wouldn't expect me as a cabinet
minister to comment on the operationally
independent metropolitan police but in
respect of the
completely unauthorized party that took
place
at conservative hq by the london mayoral
campaign it was appalling it was wrong
it should never have happened and the
people involved have been punished okay
let's uh let's move on another front
page that i don't think you'll like the
look of uh it's beginning to look a lot
like christmas terrible pun there
but the idea is that's the direction of
travel are we looking at more
restrictions ahead of christmas
well these are very difficult times and
we've seen with this surge of omicron
doubling almost every two days we're
having to take very difficult decisions
and i think anyone that that pretends
that this is simple or straightforward
is pretending however i do think right
now we have got the balance right the
key thing is the booster if you can can
you come back to the result this is a
very important this is a very important
point though about the booster because
it's only if people get that booster
that we can continue with this kind of
freedoms that we have now it gives you
75
protection against it probably more
against hospitalization that is the
plank on which we're building our
strategy um wales is bringing in new
restrictions scotland has gone further
um why are we always a step behind and
even the queen has cancelled her
christmas parties shouldn't the
messaging be clearer
well the message is clear that people
need to be sensible and cautious but
because of the vaccine because of the
booster we are confident that we can
have restrictions as they stand at the
moment alongside the further mask
wearing and so on
it's because of the strength of that
booster and that's why it's essential
that we keep getting that booster into
people's arms and we've had record
success with that yesterday with over
700 000 administered i think that is the
correct and balanced approach all right
less than what what is targeted though
at a million you are asking people to
choose effectively though aren't you
between
the advice being given by the chief
medical officer and professor chris
whitty and the government very mixed
messaging there but it appears that as
though people's trust is going with the
medical professionals we've seen the
cancellations we've seen a real drop-off
in people using public transport
they're not trusting the government on
this
well chris whitty with whom you might
imagine i speak frequently prime
minister cabinet and i are all in
agreement and the single best thing we
can do in this situation is to get the
booster rolled out as rapidly as
possible we made that big call back in
the summer to buy the pfizer in madonna
another big call by the the prime
minister that is very effective against
this new omicron variant
we're saying to everyone get your
booster if you get your booster we can
build back up that wall of defense and
continue with life as it was before just
one last question about uh chris whitty
reports in the papers that he's under
fire from tory mps for effectively
freelancing and advising people in a way
that doesn't accord with what the
government is saying is your party at
war with the cmo
well i have a great deal of respect for
for chris whitty and i think we should
respect his integrity and independence
as an advisor of course advisors advise
and ministers decide and are accountable
for the strategy off the back of that
and i know that these are difficult
times and people have what do you think
were you personally disappointed with
his intervention at the press conference
i think it's perfectly appropriate for
chris witte to advise the government
which is exactly what he has done but is
equally perfectly appropriate for the
government to make decisions off the
back of that and that's what we've done
with this strategy the core part of
which is the boost campaign i'm sorry to
keep on talking about it but it is so
essential that people get that boost one
other thing i want to talk to you about
before we get on to boosters a business
community crying out for support the
chancellor was swallowing around in
california what is going on is there any
more support for businesses well the
chancellor certainly wasn't spawning
around the chancellor was out in the
united states representing the united
kingdom meeting with leading businesses
in the united states he's also been in
constant contact for example with the
hospitality industry and the the prime
minister we have demonstrated time and
time again that we will stand behind
business when they need that support for
example when i was culture secretary i
remember when lockdown started i was
warned that we could lose a third of
football clubs two-thirds of our
cultural institutions thanks to the
record cultural recovery fund two
billion pounds we've preserved almost
all of them there's money there there's
money in relation to to business right
now i know you say that
forgive me for interrupting mr dowden um
i know you say he's meeting with
businesses in america it's very
important businesses say that they're
going to go to the wall over christmas
here they say where is he he should be
meeting with us he didn't show up to
round table yesterday he also says that
existing support is enough but the
businesses say they won't survive
through christmas so what's going to
happen is is there any hope of more
support for them
well the chancellor is is returning to
the united kingdom to today i i
understand
if you look at the kind of support
that's available take the business rate
really through to spring that will mean
that businesses are paying a quarter of
the business rates they would normally
pay for that's why we've cut v80 and
kept vat cut at 12 and a half percent
there's also over a quarter of a billion
pounds still with local authorities that
could go to support businesses and i
know the chancellor is working with them
to get that money out so we have proven
that we'll put the resources in and we
will support those businesses and i know
the chancellor's committed to doing that
all right but no new money as far as you
know at the moment as you sit here
we have already put support in place of
course we watch this hour by hour
day by day and i know the chancellor is
very closely engaged but at the moment
we have appropriate supports in place
all right oliver dowden thank you very
much for coming in to see us at sky news
have a great christmas thank you very
much merry christmas to you too
well we will be discussing the result
from that by-election in north
shropshire with the conservative mp sir
roger gale and boris johnson's former
communications director will walden
we'll be joined by the first minister of
wales mark drakeford as wales plans new
lockdown rules after christmas
and for some more reaction on last
night's by-election we'll talk to the
shadow business minister jonathan
reynolds that's just after eight o'clock
now four children all believed to be
related have died in a house fire in
south london
firefighters wearing breathing apparatus
managed to remove the youngsters from
the property in sutton and give them cpr
but were unable to revive them a warning
our report now from iva bennett does
feature some flashing images
even in the dark the charred front of
the house could be seen from beyond the
police cordon as firefighters assessed
the damage of a fire that claimed the
lives of four young children all
believed to be related
there are many here who need comfort
ellie o'neill lives nearby and rushed
home when she heard what happened
devastated for them kids
then poor children and the poor families
the poor mum and dad
what they're going to be going through
is terrible
eight fire engines and 60 firefighters
responded to the call just before 7 pm
in sutton south london
the children were given immediate cpr
after being recovered from the house
before they were taken to hospital where
they were pronounced dead the london
fire brigade said its staff here will be
offered counselling as a priority
the cause of the fire is still unknown
and is now under investigation the
police say no arrests have been made and
that the family of the children have
been informed and will be given
specialist support
in a statement superintendent rob
shepard said the thoughts of everyone at
the south area command unit are with the
family and friends of these four young
children who have suffered such a
devastating and tragic loss tonight
i know these sentiments will be shared
by the local community sutton and london
as a whole
it took firefighters an hour and a half
to get the flames under control
the pain and loss here will last for a
great deal longer iva bennett sky news
sutton
now all night clubs will close in wales
that is part of new lockdown
restrictions that are coming into force
after christmas wales has announced it
is toughening up its coveted measures
after boxing day to try to tackle the
spread of the omicron variant well from
the 27th of december 2 meter social
distancing will become a legal
requirement in shops and businesses
one-way systems and physical barriers to
keep people apart will also return and
businesses will be required to let staff
work from home wherever possible and
nightclubs will be forced to close as
well
now it will be jabs around the clock
this weekend as more 24-hour vaccine
centers open across the country well
sadia chaudhary is at one now in crawley
a morning to you sadie a massive
operation being undertaken there
good morning sam yes in just under an
hour these doors will open and they will
remain open because this is one of the
first 24-hour vaccination sites in the
country it is the first in the southeast
and that means people can come as you
say around the clock to get their
vaccinations and the target here is to
vaccinate a thousand people a day
and you won't ex
you don't expect to see long queues here
because most of those appointments are
appointments only but they have said to
me that if they see that there is a gap
coming up there it might be quiet or
there are some cancellations then
they'll get on social media invite
people in the local area to come and do
a walk-in but you know there is a big
car park here so people can wait in
their cars before but also after the jab
we know that 15-minute rule has gone but
if anyone is of any concern they can
wait
in their cars and they're doing this in
a dedicated vaccination site that they
built specifically for the vaccine
program
and since last year they vaccinated this
gp alliance vaccinated around 90 000
people but that looks to be stepped up
very sharply now with this 24-hour
program starting from today yeah busy
day ahead sadia thank you very much
well let's look into some more detail
now at the latest daily covid figures
for the uk well there have been 88
376 new cases of covert 19 recorded in
the last 24 hours that is the highest
number of the pandemics so far and
almost 10 000 more than yesterday
another 146 deaths have been reported
within 28 days of a positive test well
that brings the total number of deaths
in the uk to 146
9937 while hearing there about the
vaccine program 28 067 people received
their first dose of a vaccine 38 794
have had their second and the total
number of people to have received their
second dose is now approaching
47 million
well and another new record uh 740
183 people received their booster or
third vaccine in the past 24 hours that
brings the total to more than 25.4
million people
well to japan now where at least 27
people are reported to have died in a
suspected arson attack on a psychiatric
clinic in the japanese city of osaka
well joining me now is our asia
correspondent tom cheshire this is a
terrible tragedy tom what's happened
morning samia this is a horrifying fire
that started
around 10 a.m just after this
psychiatric clinic had opened its doors
in a shopping district in osaka which is
japan's second biggest city um people
there reported smoke billowing out the
windows so a very fierce fire
you can see on the screen right now
what's happened after it but people
saying they saw a woman at the windows
calling for help that help did come 70
fire engines were at the scene and the
fire was extinguished relatively quickly
in around 20 minutes or so but still 27
people are believed to be feared dead
and the reason we're saying fear dead is
because in japan uh you need a doctor to
certify a death and that hasn't happened
uh yet in those cases firefighters said
27 people were in cardiac arrest at the
scene so the theory is that that death
toll will be confirmed four people have
been confirmed death accord dead
according to the national broadcaster in
japan the focus now on what started that
fire and police saying they are
investigating the possibility of arson
local media reports suggesting that an
elderly man was seen walking into the
building uh supposedly a patient
carrying a bag full of flammable liquid
that was leaking those are unconfirmed
as yet but we'll bring back memories of
that horrible 2019 arsenal attack where
more than 30 people were killed at an
animation studio that is unconfirmed
right now police are working at the
scene trying to understand what happened
here as well as people in hospitals
working to see whether that death toll
will sadly rise
okay tom thank you
well also making the news this morning
lawyers for guillaine maxwell have tried
to undermine the credibility of her
female accusers during her sex
trafficking trial in new york the
british socialite has pleaded not guilty
to recruiting and grooming young girls
for the convicted pedophile jeffrey
epstein
a court in the united states has issued
a search warrant for alec baldwin's
phone after the fatal shooting of the
cinematographer helena hutchins on the
set of the film rust helena hutchins was
killed in october when a gun that the
actor was holding during filming was
fired
sky news understands the transport
secretary grant shaps has told staff he
is deeply unhappy about a party that was
held at his department during last
year's lockdown the cabinet secretary
has now started an investigation into
that the department has apologized and
insists it was a low-key gathering
officials say the deaths of 10 people in
a crowd surge at a music festival in
houston last month were accidental
investigators in texas say that their
findings were delayed due to further
tests being carried out on the victims
let's have a check in with the weather
now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar
airways well it's a very quiet picture
in the days ahead with high pressure
dominating but fog over eastern areas
will be dense at times and slow to clear
bringing possible travel disruption this
morning the fog lies over eastern
counties from yorkshire to east anglia
visibility is less than 50 meters in
places and it'll be slow to lift through
the day lingering throughout for some
fog bound areas we'll see daytime
temperatures of around three or four
degrees
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the voters gave us a kicking those
were the words of the conservative party
chairman oliver dowden this morning
after the liberal democrats took a shock
victory in the north shropshire
by-election they overturned a majority
of nearly 23 000 in a result which adds
to the turmoil surrounding the prime
minister
what a short time ago mr dowden admitted
it was a bad result for the
conservatives
voters in north shropshire were fed up
and they gave us a kicking
and i think they wanted to send us a
message and i want to say as chairman of
the conservative party we've heard that
loud and clear
we need to get on with delivering the
job and that's precisely what we're
doing
well we can get more now on that
by-election result from north shropshire
after a triumphant night the leader of
the liberal democrats ed davey joins me
this morning uh what a night for the lib
dems
i think this is a war to shared moment
in british politics it was such a
spectacular result i'm obviously really
delighted for helen morgan our new
liberal democrat mp for north shropshire
but i'm so proud of our party and our
campaigners i think we brought some new
hope to the whole nation and i think
we've shown uh that we can beat the
conservatives anywhere we've beaten the
conservatives in two of their safest
seats this year early this year in
darkest blue buckminster
and now in north shropshire so i think
people will be encouraged that boris
johnson and conservatives can be held to
account and liberal democrats can do
that
well the party is over seemed to be a
pretty effective slogan for you what
kind of things were you hearing on the
doorstep and when did you get the sense
that this could go your way
well i traveled five times to north
shropshire had 10 days campaigning there
so i talked to a lot of voters and
actually to start they were really
talking about issues like the health
service
long waiting times for ambulances
difficulties to see their gps the rising
costs of living
and they felt the conservatives were
taking them for granted had taken them
for granted for many years and these are
people who've played by the rules who've
always voted conservative and now
they're turning to the liberal democrats
and you know i i think those local
issues must be remembered of course
there were national issues and i'm not
surprised boris johnson after his
shocking peppa pig speech and and all
this party gates uh where they've broken
the rules that they've told us to follow
i'm not surprised that he's now losing
uh support of lifelong conservatives and
many of them said to me
many of them said to me they don't just
so sorry to interrupt you there mr davis
just saying the party chairman was
saying yes the voters did give us a
kicking but with full confidence in
boris johnson prime minister and how
long do you think that is going to
remain the status quo
well i think the conservative chairman
should listen a bit more closely to the
people of north shropshire they were
telling me that they don't think boris
johnson is a decent person not a decent
person to lead our country and frankly
i think the people of north shropshire
have sent in a letter of no confidence
in boris johnson to
the conservative 1922 committee uh i
think conservative mps will be very
alarmed by this result uh because these
were lifelong conservatives dismayed at
boris johnson's lack of decency saying
they don't like him they don't want him
and so you know i felt for a long time i
felt that he's not fit to lead our
country and i think more and more people
now who used to trust boris johnson no
longer
do very good result for you in this
particular constituency mr davey but you
still have relatively few
mps
is this an inflection point do you think
for the liberal democrats after the
coalition which really drastically
damaged your electoral prospects
i think this is a historic moment for
the liberal democrats let's remember we
won a major uh by-election victory
earlier this year
in cheshire in blue buckinghamshire
where we we took a first brick out of
the conservative blue wall
since then we've been selecting amazing
candidates in seats that we're going to
be targeting the next general election
seats from guildford to eastbourne from
cheltenham to wimbledon and now we won
another seat in a former conservative
heartland and now we're going to go on
to the local election so i think the
liberal democrats are on a roll now i
think people like what we say
about a fairer deal for people over the
health service over schools of the cost
of living and people responding very
positively to our message uh they think
that we're in them and the tories are
out of touch
all right i just want to say mr david i
don't know if it's your lighting but i
know you've got covered you don't look
very well how are you feeling uh not
great i'll be honest uh i'm under the
weather but the sun is shining on the
liberal democrats
a dreadful note uh on which on which to
leave it there um but uh thank you very
much indeed for speaking to us this
morning davey thank you
well we can get reaction now from the
conservative member of parliament for
north vanet sir roger gail good morning
to you sir roger did you think this was
possible what we saw in north shropshire
yes
i i thought it was highly likely that
this would happen i don't want to
detract from helen morgan's very
considerable victory
but this wasn't a vote for liberal
democrats this was effectively a
referendum on the performance coming out
of downing street at the moment
it's been a terrible few weeks hasn't it
for the prime minister where does this
leave his authority in the party do you
think
he has got the good fortune of having
the house in recess
the house has got time to think about
this and the party's got time to think
about this
he's got about three weeks now to
regroup
and he's going to have to do that very
fast indeed we've had two strikes
um first of all the conservative party
in the house of commons
earlier this week
now this result
one more strike and i think he's out
really
those letters are going in are they to
the 1922 committee
i would not be a bit surprised if people
didn't start to write some of those
letters
um we got the south end by election
coming up now that's going to be an odd
situation because the liberal party and
the labour party have because of the
circumstances of david amos's death
agreed not to fight it but it will be
fought
and it's quite possible i think that if
we're not careful there might be a
protest vote there as well
um
this is not a happy time for the prime
minister i'm afraid
how widely are those conversations about
replacing him as leader
how widely are those conversations
taking place
i'm speaking for myself and not for the
consecutive party i must make that
absolutely plain
um
i have written to segregate brady but i
did that um
after the barnard castle business
um because i felt then
that there was a lack of the right kind
of leadership and and i made that view
known and i've been making it known
since
um so a lot of people will say well
that's just roger gayle saying what
roger gahill says
i can't tell you what the rest of the
party is saying but i have an idea that
will be a lot of people who are very
concerned this morning
there are further accusations in the
newspapers this morning about downing
street parties including one which
claims that the prime minister himself
was attending during the first lockdown
you said before that this could be a
resignation matter and these stories
keep coming
i've said and i mean that if the prime
minister is shown
to have deliberately misled the house i
mean deliberately mislead the house from
the dispatch box
then in my view that is a resignation
issue
uh we have to see what the cabinet
secretary says
the other thing i would say is that
nobody particularly wants a leadership
election
in the middle of a pandemic
now is not the best time there's never a
good time but now is not the best time
to embark upon that road so the prime
minister has got an opportunity to
regroup
get his act together
and give us the
kind of government that i think most of
us thought was going to be on the cards
do you think he's got it in him
he's a man of great ability
if he focuses his mind on what is really
necessary if he focuses his mind
on what not only the conservative party
but the people of this country want
and starts to deliver in a big way and
he's delivered some things that are good
if he starts to deliver in a big way
then he might survive this but it is
touch and go
so roger gail good to talk to you this
morning thank you for your time on sky
news
well our political correspondent rob
powell is in oswestry
for us there uh shockwaves of this uh
going out far and wide and many
questions being raised rob about the
prime minister's hold on his party
yeah an indication there sam from sir
roger gail of the impact that this
by-election result
may well have
on internal politics in the conservative
party in westminster so roger gail an mp
for almost 40 years so someone
who i think is more freely able to speak
his mind and be honest publicly than
some mps may be willing to be yes he has
been at the critical end previously
about boris johnson but i think very
significant that roger gail um is saying
he wouldn't be surprised if letters are
going in that there was one strike with
that commons defeat uh that rebel sorry
that commons rebellion against boris
johnson earlier um this week on cover of
restrictions that this by-election is
the second and the third strike um and
he will be out and essentially putting
boris johnson on notice saying um that
he now has the christmas break to go
away to think about what's happened
and to come back um and regroup
essentially um i think roger roger gale
is correct when he says that this
by-election was uh almost more of a
referendum on what's going on in
government as much as as sir davey talks
about this as a watershed moment for the
lib dems and talks about local issues
which of course always play a part in by
elections the lib dems focused heavily
on the sleaze row around o and patterson
they focused heavily on the allegations
around christmas parties um as well so i
think um it is worth thinking about this
result in that context rather than
necessarily extrapolating it out to a
general election in terms of what the
conservative party centrally is saying
today well actually i thought oliver
dowden was quite frank saying that they
did take a kicking here that voters are
fed up and that they are listening to
that
loud and clear i guess the question is
is that message getting through to boris
johnson
is he able to change to grip um some of
the problems facing his government and
stop seemingly lurching from crisis to
crisis
and what can he do to make that happen
in the coming weeks and months all right
rob thank you very much well boris
johnson's communications director at
city hall he's now senior council at
edelman will walden joins me now a very
good morning to you mr walden questions
being raised about whether or not the
message of this by-election result is
going to get through to boris johnson
you know the man will the message be
getting through
uh morning sam uh
look there's no getting away from this
this is a thumping at the time when the
prime minister's authority is already
under threat and i think it's very
difficult to do what they always do
which is to brush this off as a typical
by-election mid-term blip and i suspect
the pm this morning is privately kicking
himself it's a largely self-inflicted
wound it's a by-election that should
never have happened
and it comes on the back of some very
damaging headlines and if i was a tory
activist or a tory mp this morning yeah
i'd be concerned but more importantly if
i was a prime minister this morning i'd
be concerned the result here should
never have been in doubt this is a tory
seat it's been a tourist seat for nearly
200 years and i think there's a clear
message here from the tory heartland in
shropshire
it's get your act together to your point
about um you know whether he can sort
this out and i i think the first thing i
would be saying to him if he asked if i
was still advising him would be you know
take a break um i i think you know he's
had some huge responsibilities over the
last couple of years i think he needs to
recharge he needs to reassess his
priorities and think about what what
really matters
you know look boris johnson is not a man
um who changes easily uh uh but i think
that that clearly this is a wake-up call
and a very present wake-up call and he
will need to think about the tone that
he sets in downing street and the way
that he runs his government
and government more generally will have
to think about what the priorities are
and how they're going to act upon them
because you know clearly there is no
getting away from the fact that this is
a really big problem for the prime
minister
we are understanding that the prime
minister is going to give a speech at
the start of january he's going to seek
to really be wiping the slate clean of
all of the torrid few weeks that he's
had in the run-up
to christmas the last time he gave a big
speech though it didn't go so well how
is he going to be preparing for this
well i think you're probably referring
to the um the peppa pig moment uh i mean
none of that came as any surprise to me
that that's for us all over um i i think
it's not so much how is he going to be
preparing for it it is what is the tone
that he is he is going to set
and i think you know if i had any advice
for him this morning it would be he may
have to break the habit of a lifetime
and think that
in future he's going to have to act with
a little bit more humble pie and
probably stop acting as if he's
constantly at war i think it's
extraordinary for a government that has
an 80-seat majority that they constantly
look like they're firefighting and at
war and i think that the part of that is
about
um thinking about um you know apologies
in the appropriate moment so for example
on the on the christmas party gate you
know i would have thought they probably
would have been better rather than
doubling down which is a boris johnson
trait there's no surprise in that uh
thinking about that and thinking
maybe we need to get out ahead of this
maybe we need to to stand up and just
say look mistakes were made you know i
don't know honest mistakes were made
mistakes were made it's bad we apologize
you know we we discipline those
responsible and i think the problem is
they're now having an inquiry led by
simon case which is probably going to do
just that the best thing to do would
have been to think you know we're not
going to be able to ride this through
let's get in front of it let's apologize
for it and let's move on and i think as
to us to the broader point you know i go
back to the point that the prime
minister sets the tone you know he
always sets the tone and i think he's
going to have to think about the tone
that he sets in terms of his government
and the way that things operate in
downing street there's a lot of
criticism about oh he's got the wrong
advice and the wrong advisers i i think
ultimately you know this is a
government-wide problem but it's also a
boris problem and i think you know
knowing boris he'll know that and he'll
be reflecting on that and and he should
take christmas to take a break spend
time with his new baby and come back
reset in the new year
all right will bolton uh good to get
your perspective this morning on sky
news thank you
thanks sam
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
friday morning will be mostly dry mild
and cloudy but there'll be some dense
fog around mainly across eastern england
from yorkshire to east anglia travel
disruption is possible scotland and
areas north west of high ground will
have the best of the sunshine it'll be a
touch cooler than recently but very mild
on the scottish hills the afternoon will
be similar with fog lingering all day in
parts of the east
despite the settled conditions air
pollution levels will stay low measuring
between 1 and 3 on the daily air quality
index
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now all night clubs will close in wales
that's as part of new lockdown
restrictions that are coming into force
after christmas well here to tell us
more about the new rules is the first
minister of wales mark drakeford good
morning to you mr drakeford what is the
current situation of the spread of
omicron in wales
well wales is in the calm before the
storm
uh this week the delta variant continues
to be the dominant variant in wales
numbers are stable
hospital numbers slowly coming down
but we know that the omicron wave is
brewing
and that when it arrives in wales it
will rise very swiftly and very steeply
and so we're having to prepare for that
as well
so talk us through mr drakeford if you
would these tighter measures
well before christmas we will be issuing
new strong guidance to people in wales
as to how they can keep themselves and
others safe in the run-up to christmas
very simple things like if you are going
out to a gathering of any sort
make sure you've taken a lateral flow
test flow before you go as we tell
people in wales think about who you're
meeting
are you going to be meeting somebody who
is vulnerable because of their own
health and make that part of your plan
could you meet outdoors instead of
indoors are you doing all those simple
things the mask wearing the hand washing
the simple things we've learned to do
that help to keep one another safe
provided we all do that
we think we can get a run through to
christmas where people can enjoy
christmas but stay safe at christmas as
well
immediately after the christmas night
clubs to close from the 27th so viruses
don't wait for christmas why not sooner
uh because as i say in the
days ahead up to christmas the delta
variant will be the dominant one here
in wales and the safeguards we have in
place the covet paths you have to use to
go to a nightclub for example
we think that that will be sufficient to
keep whales safe but because we know
that the omicron variant is here already
and is guaranteed to grow
we need to take action after the
christmas break so nightclubs will not
reopen
when shops reopen then the rules will be
stricter
controls on the number of people
entering shops one-way systems
organized queuing at checkouts and so on
when offices reopen the two-meter rule
will be back as part of the reasonable
measures that have to be taken in wales
all of those things designed
to shore up our defenses
against the
one of the problems that wales had in
previous lockdowns is that you would
impose restrictions and people would
just go across the border so what's
what's to stop people going doing their
nightclubbing their post-christmas
nightclubbing over in
england uh well you're right that the
border is very poor some people who live
across the border can make those choices
uh it's a very small fraction of the
large population
that is in that position and makes those
decisions
we're seeing already not just in wales
but across the united kingdom people
making decisions in their own lives to
keep themselves safe and that's what we
will be appealing to people in wales to
do there is a big wave coming our way
and unless we do the sensible things
lives that otherwise could be saved will
be lost
our health service will face an enormous
challenge we can all do things to help
and that's what people in wales i know
will want to do
i know you're urging people in wales to
have a smaller christmas to restrict the
number of people that they're mixing
with at the national level do you think
that that message is coming across
clearly
from prime minister boris johnson about
what he expects the people to do
well the uk government is now embarked
on a major advertising campaign and
their advertising campaign is in line
with our message
to people in wales that a smaller
christmas is a safer christmas this year
we know that that takes place against a
very difficult backdrop because of
everything that has gone on inside
downing street and inside the uk
government
despite all that
i hope that people across the united
kingdom will hear that message we are
all of us facing a very difficult
january
we can all help
to deal with that and i hope that the
messages that all governments across the
united kingdom are giving will be
listened to and will be acted upon
what do you make of the chief medical
officer coming under fire according to
reports and papers by many tory mps for
freelancing and for frightening people
for just suggesting that they should
prioritize their social interactions is
that responsible
uh it's not responsible at all i think
it is disgraceful that the chief medical
officer of england should come
under attack
in that way
the chief medical officer is giving the
best advice he can
from his depth of clinical knowledge and
understanding it is very good advice
indeed and i think it is disgraceful
that he should be attacked and his
message undermined by people who have
nothing like
the grasp that he has
of the omicron variant and it's likely
affecting the united kingdom uh i think
those people should think very carefully
about a period of silence on their part
first minister of wales mark drakeford
really good to talk